peggy's 16
you
why it is an action-adventure game about
the relationship between man and nature
we want the player to experience things
to learn how the wide world works you
are character already written the
experience that you're in the game for
example you've got a lot of tattoos on
the body every tattoo is an experience
of your character the world is huge so
you can explore and have the feeling of
freedom we are working on an open-world
game with a very large world and we can
go anywhere we want anyone we don't have
any restriction on this side
this variation for wild really comes
from my childhood I was spending a lot
of time in the wild nature it's
something that is there in my mind for a
long time I've been working on games
where the forest and the wild world is
very important for example Raymond
starting in the jungle we develop the
universe of while I asked the team to go
in the white nature like a surviving
experience and feel and smell and really
immersed in what is the wide world we
wanted to go in while in odd places to
get a lot of real materials in order to
build our character all objects in the
general environment the journey of and
objects from the real world to the game
is going through a process which is
photogrammetry so we take a lot of
pictures and then it's building the 3d
model of the object directly from those
pictures so we can use real wide objects
in our real white game every time I hire
people it is my first question do you
have animals at home do you like animals
every five second we come up with a new
idea of what a cool thing an animal
would do is this kind of constant
inspiration just in nature
so you've just seen our trailer up
arrogance week and I'm going to go
through the gameplay demo and show you
what school being white saver German I
really wanted the main character to
carry the values of the game like for
example is not a wire so it's got it
would stick because it's more sorcerer
is a shaman and the main thing is fact
that you can jump from a human character
to any animal I can call an ego for
example the White Eagle van what makes
the game really cool is that when you
call the world like that you can go into
is a spirit and control the barrel and
you've got a new point of view of the
same world so once you you control your
ego you realize that the angle is a
hunter I'm here we want to hunt a new
animal because in white you can catch
any anymore and Simon the divinity of
this anymore
another very nice things that you can
call JM bells and you can use them as
very powerful vehicles
it's a very nice way to have another
perspective and those are point of view
of the same name but your biggest in
mean why is the other humans if for
example we are arriving in a cannibal
camp which is very dangerous i'm going
to use another animal this is very
interesting because you will see air
combinations of game plays with
different animals and then attack
then i can continue my way to the j and
divinity my goal is to then take my
snake and Simon the snake divinity the
divinities represent the forces of
nature they can be unpredictable they
can be dangerous maybe the divinity with
a score very dangerous challenge to
prove that I have the knowledge of the
snakes so everything is never easy win
you have to prove that you understand
the world wide ps4 for the players